zukauf
business solution more muskel
extra damit die auf ihrem sofa und kann
mich aus hamburg rübergefahren heute und
vielleicht weil ich die nächsten tage
mit behältern in österreich bin
gut wir gehören die ganze box sachen
aufbaut ist dann einfach baden gegangen
manchmal auch
unter last seht ihr den pickel ich weiß
ihr wollt den ausdrücken aber ich mach
das später selber zu
drücken dazu nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin manchmal wenig krautköpfe ich
verwehre mich gegen dich aber ich habe
keinen bock das ist ein strahlender
dafür
was ein komischer was macht ein wurm
wenn er frisst
in frage
das
passt wird vergessen dass sie einfach
mal mit geschlossenen augen in nagoya
die beiden süßen die haben jetzt podcast
fertig aufgenommen
und da wollte ich einfach mal fragen
was ist das gegenteil von reformhaus
daraus
was ist gelb und schießt den ball ohne
da ist die wirklich gespielt von mir was
machen mathematiker im garten wurzeln
ziehen
finde ich mich auch so witzig
ich glaube ich mache das sehr selten
komplett weil leider vom bezahlsender
ich bin ja noch mal kurzem eine kölner
wohnung hier übergegangen weil die ja
gerade umgebaut wird und
ich erkenne nicht wieder auf jeden fall
veröffentlichen sondern man nicht noch
länger bleibe heute
es ist einfach alles
also ich frage mich wirklich nichts mehr
bei den städten wir machen übrigens
geraten roth führt nach
österreich grund sie der braut falls
euch fragt warum er nach österreich
fahren das weiß ich auch nicht
nach österreich weil sie bei uns machen
will ich will skifahren sie hat gesagt
okay wir können skifahrer letzten
unterwegs sagt sie wir gehen doch nicht
sicher
da jetzt noch drei stunden 750 fans
haben wie mir jetzt lodges spiel und
zwar stadland beleidigungen h
statt mit l
hier machen wir weiter mit land litauen
würde ich sagen luxemburg ok beleidigung
manchmal wünsche ich war kein personen
real life blockieren dass ich einfach
nicht mehr sehen oder hören wirst du ein
kleiner tipp übrigens falls sie
irgendwann entführt werden sollte und im
kofferraum liegt was
wenn ihr ein film werde dann schaut euch
dieses video wenn ihr im kofferraum
liegt unterarme sind irgendwie zusammen
gebunden oder so tretet die
rückleuchten raus man könnte dann fuß
haushalten oder so
genau auf alles vorbereitet sein
stiefvater für dieses größere größen das
auch so ein richtiger im fall polanski
an mobile kalibrierung die im zehnten
super unternehmen aber zu police noch
morgens schnall dich besser an wenn am
steuer setzt
das ist
keystone
stau
stehende autos hagenschieß siedlung die
worte hier sind wie die mülheimer in
hamburg neubärental
romberg heimsheim rom eine stadt hesse
honigstand stadt denkendorf würde nicht
so und jetzt merken war das war in
bayern angekommen sind also wir sind
jetzt gerade in
[Musik]
den füßen wie findet ihr meine neue
rolex verletzten sollten kostenlos sein
da wo wir grad herr fall ist wie ich
[Musik]
wir haben den zwei stunden 7
gefahrenbremsung und drei tote vögel das
stimmt ja das stimmt nein doch es habe
macht die besten cookies der welt sind
in österreich angekommen
gott gewinn
smoking klaus und wo sie es prosieben
mein stylist heute einfach nur frech was
ist wenn alle pferde weggelaufen sind
dann ist der stand er
in einem hotel angekommen und wichtig
dass erst mal bitte nicht schon da und
sind jetzt mal ein bisschen durch die
innenstadt gelaufen und die ganze stadt
besteht aus skiverleih leben und bars
gehen jetzt etwas einkaufen
[Musik]
das fand jetzt nicht so lustig versteht
ihr wegen
okay
aber
auch ganz ehrlich normalerweise mag ich
auch nicht die spritkosten werden echt
auch immer teurer
versteht ihr wegen breit spritkosten
ich glaube ich muss gleich rein die
witze sind aber auch ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich spät fiel
diesmal nicht so viel ich habe mich 24
stunden nicht gemeldet aber wir machen
gerade zwar
war
das hier hinter mir sind übrigens alles
weinflaschen diese annahme getrunken hat
eine schönere
[Musik]
erst einmal übrigens in österreich der
komplette himmel gelb ich weiß jetzt
dass auf dem foto yoda kommt und das lag
einfach an so sahara finden die von der
wüste afrikas rübergeflogen sind bis
nach österreich und haben uns halt
morgen ins auto gesetzt und
es ist einfach raus ein hausdach
geschissen da vorne ist übrigens die
zugspitze könnte allerdings nicht den
hauch von der ganzen scheiße auf dem
auto einfach erschlagen der ort heißt
einfach sie und er sehe in der stadt ist
ein ort oder was
in st
spiderman der trick ändert was hat ein
kannibale unter der dusche
[Musik]
head and shoulders was ist schwarz-weiß
und sind auf einer schaukel
schwing grün weiß warum polizisten immer
eine schere mit dabei haben damit sie
den dieben den weg abschneiden können
[Musik]
da ist sicherlich comedypreis habe ich
schon erzählt dass ich heute aus dem
topf akkus geflogen bin
ich habe mich im ton vergriffen
das nicht witzig was hat nur einen arm
und kann nicht schlimm
magath
er denkt sich diese scheiß name aus der
zeit heraus die sonne 14-jährigen der
kamera
ja es ist wenn engländer regen verkaufen
will
gar nicht ich habe jetzt mal ich kann
man locker genommen hätten für die
sachen aus aber ich bin jetzt mal den
block und erlöst euch mal von den ganzen
schlechten witzen